depuis quelques temps je reçois très
souvent ce genre de message beaucoup
norman je voulais savoir si tu pouvais
faire des vidéos où tu répond à nos
questions comme cyprien et squeeze alors
je me suis dit pourquoi pas allez c'est
parti
pourquoi as-tu appelé ton chat cergy ou
en fait la base je suis assez fan du
chanteur serge gainsbourg et j'ai appelé
mon chat serge gainsbourg je crois que
l'on était un peu long un peu nul à dire
tu vois serge gainsbourg serge
gainsbourg voilà c'était excessivement
longue et ridicule
du coup j'ai évidemment génie serge
serge est comme moi je suis quelqu'un
qui aime tous les minions un fils qui
est tout ce qu'il ya diminutif ça s'est
très vite transformée en énergie je pose
une question
ah bah non je ça justement c'est une
affirmation capable de dire qu'on prénom
le plus rapidement possible sans
trébucher aaa
normal c'était difficile c'est quoi la
marque de ton shampoing alors s'ils
s'appellent white spirit
tu me dire combien alors ça signifie le
monde peut souvent la caméra comme elle
un petit peu en plongée on dirait que ce
petit chien visage de petits et je
mesure 1 m 85
as-tu déjà mis ta main dans une cheminée
trop vite pleins de toi par contre été
éteintes
tu as eu quelle mention au bac arts
excellence que tu dis ça comme si
évidemment j'avais une mention pasqua je
me souviens qu'au bac comme mention j'ai
eu pas de mention 1
estimez vous heureux de l'avoir fils de
chien penses tu que tout est relatif
ça dépend pour quoi tu ne te présente
pas aux élections présidentielles parce
que si j'étais président de la
république tu vois je pense que la
france
ça ressemblerait à ça
ton boisson préférée je pense que mon
boisson préférée c'est le lièvre
quelle est ta série musique chaînes tv
gâteau portable goûter préférés quel est
ton gamertag sur lol dota attends je
crois que je choisis une vidéo spéciale
pour répondre tu as ta question
ton genre de fille franchement moi
j'aime bien les me fait un peu dans ce
style là franchement moi j'aime bien
tous les types de vie tant qu'elles sont
gentils tu attends qu elles sont
sincères naturel tant qu'il ya de la
gentillesse qui passe dans le regard
comme ça pas moi ça me convient si tu
n'aurais pas été youtuber à ton avis
corps et tu étais avant de faire des
vidéos j'ai fait pas mal de petits jobs
alimentaires et puis j'ai fini par être
monteur en fait mon fer vidéo pendant
deux ans donc je pense que j'aurais
continué à être mis en oeuvre
ça te fait quoi d'avoir une calvitie a à
peine 26 ans bord déjà j'ai la chance de
pas du tout avoir de calais ici et à
quel moment tu t'ai dis je des pechos
des meufs en m'appelant sur twitter ben
laden
sinon ça c'est vraiment cessé dix ans à
quoi tu ressemblais quand tu étais petit
[Musique]
tu vas tu faire un one man show alors
beaucoup m'ont posé de question et la
réponse est oui
comme certains le savent en parallèle à
mes vidéos je suis aussi du one man show
depuis plus d'un an maintenant et la sai
et j'annonce donc la tournée officielle
qui commence en septembre prochain
ce qui est cool c'est que j'ai pas que
dans les grandes villes je vais aussi
dans les petites villes et puis enfin je
serai à paris à la cigale à partir de
février 2015 pour voir si je viens jouer
dans votre ville et pour réserver des
places j'ai mis un petit lien dans la
description en tout la vidéo bon je suis
bien photoshopée on dirait que j'ai 8
ans ça c'est parce qu'à la base je suis
très moche même jour eux j'ai aussi eu
certaines questions un peu spécial
donc je vais quand même vous en parler
pourquoi t'es arabe
[Musique]
je ne suis pas arabe
un e-mail musulmans même si j'ai dans
mon frigo des produits halal 1 voilà que
je consomme
merci à john rachid est ce que tu as
déjà pleuré en faisant kaka genre des
fois ça fait mal tu as l'impression que
c'est une fusée qui sort ligh headlight
a vraiment un souci mental contre pu
venir à bx pour ton one man show alors
si bx ça veut dire bordeaux oui ou alors
si bx ça veut dire bruxelles oui par
contre si tu parles de la ville de bx je
crois pas tu fais tu quand tu es tout
seul chez toi avec une meuf
si vous êtes vision comme tout le monde
[Musique]
on mange des kebabs comment il s'appelle
cergy
pas mal what le mec twitts ha de pin new
york normal silhouette comble vidéos
préférées alors c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment je joue pas mal à leur stone un
gérard prêtre level 26 1 c'est à dire
que j'ai un certain niveau
ah non mais là j'avais j'avais pas une
bonne pioche
quelles activités quotidiennes préfères
tu vas fermer vidéo c'est clairement fr
delà du one man show aussi mais je te
cache pas qu'avec les filles
j'aime bien manger des kebabs et après
j'espère d'accord et ouais et je disais
voilà c'est terminé
j'espère que ça vous a plu dites moi ce
que vous en pensez dans les commentaires
d'accord fera plus tard un autre
question est bon ce qui c'est un cas
cela ne tienne allez ciao donc hier
j'étais avec la soeur annie qu on dit
pas la soeur annie qu on dit la soeur de
nico wafa bon bref en tout cas on va
manger des haricots et amoureux nous
préparons on dit pas les haricots ont
dit les haricots
merci